WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
Android Studio 3.0
introduces an integrated view
for providing the memory, CPU,
and network request
characteristics of your app.
It's a complete overhaul
of the previous tools found
under the Android Monitor
tab, which we've now
renamed to Android Profiler.
If you're profiling with an
API 26, so Android O or above,
device or emulator,
you're all set.
You can profile any APK,
regardless of the build
system it was created with.
If you connect the Profiler to
a device with a lower API level,
you might see this warning.
Because we need to
instrument your code
to take full advantage of the
Profiler on older devices,
you should use Android Studio
to build and deploy your app.
The main view of the Profiler
presents a unified timeline
showing you the user
charts for CPU, memory,
and network in real time.
At the top, you can also
see important app events
such as user input, activity
state transitions, and device
rotations, giving you more
context for the data below.
Clicking on any of
the three charts
takes you to one of
the detailed views.
Let's check out the
CPU Profiler first.
The UI shows a live CPU
utilization graph, and the list
of all threads in your
app and their states,
such as when they
were active or waiting
for I/O. You can get a detailed
trace of methods executed
in a given period by
pressing the record button.
One thing to note
is the trace type.
Sampled has a smaller overhead,
but is not as accurate,
meaning it could miss
the execution of a very
short-lived method.
Instrumented means
that the Profiler
will record every method,
enter, and exit, accurately.
On pre-Android O devices,
there's a limit to how much
data can be recorded.
So be aware that the
instrumented trace capture
will reach that limit faster.
If you want to
increase the limit
or change the
sampling rate, you can
do that in the Edit
Configuration window here.
After you've
finished the capture,
select the thread
you're interested in.
The Top Down view shows a tree
of methods and their callees,
aggregating trace information
for identical methods
that share the same call stack,
similar to the flame chart.
The Bottom Up tab
displays a list of method
calls where expanding a method's
node displays its callers.
You can see a graphical
representation
on the call chart,
which shows time
spent in each call on
the horizontal axis.
The Memory Profiler
shows a real-time chart
of memory used by
your app attributed
to various buckets such as Java,
native, graphics, et cetera.
You can see any garbage
collection events
on the timeline, and
you can force one
using the button
on the top left.
You can dump the
heap at any moment
and examine instance
properties of objects.
The References tab can help
you figure out memory leaks
by listing all
references, pointing
to the object being examined.
There's one more feature that
is very useful for tracking
memory use over time--
allocation tracking.
If you're profiling
against a device running
API 26 or higher, you
can simply highlight
any part of the
timeline, and you'll
get a list of all objects
allocated and deallocated
within that period,
including the call
stack of the allocation.
On API 25 and lower, you
will need to explicitly
start and stop recording
allocations using
the record button, similar
to how the CPU method
tracing works.
Another difference is that
on lower API versions,
the call stacks are, by default,
capped to a depth of 16 frames.
There is a system
property you can
set prior to running your
app to temporarily enable
deeper stack traces.
Finally, let's look at
the Network Profiler.
The line labeled Radio
shows a high-level overview
of the networking
state of the device.
By looking at it, you
can tell how often
the device is
waking up the radio
into a high-powered state,
which might suggest you're not
batching your network requests
correctly and wasting battery
life.
The chart below shows actual
network connection activity,
including bytes
sent and received.
Whenever advanced
profiling is switched on
or you're running on a
compatible API 26 device,
you can highlight
any slice of time
and inspect all network calls
made, including actual HTTP
request and response
data and the call
stack where the call happened.
We even show previews for
images and enable syntax
highlighting for XML and JSON.
If you've ever used anything
like Chrome's DevTools Network
tab, this view should
look very familiar.
It's great for debugging your
app's HTTP server interactions
and data consumption.
The HTTP call
inspection is currently
enabled for the standard
HttpURLConnection
class and the OkHttp
client but should also
work with other libraries
built on top of these APIs.
So that's it for the
three new Profilers.
We are shipping the first
version in Android Studio 3.0
and will be continuing
to add new features.
I hope they'll prove useful
in debugging performance
issues in your apps.
And if there are any
features you'd like to see,
let us know on
the issue tracker.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]